this week on ford jules and i discussed
independent voters what i meant to say
on bill maher but didn't
meta
amazon tick tock twitter all of the tech
companies this week on forward
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back i am on fired uh
and you have a haircut
oh well thank you thank you for noticing
jules i appreciate it i do get those
every once in a while uh got back from
la where i did bill maher what did you
think how did i do i thought it was
really cool i i'm not an avid bill maher
watcher but i loved the panel discussion
so
well that's good because that's what i
was a part of yes it was very good you
know i will say okay so i'll just have
some fun with this uh the the best part
of being there was that i really bonded
with the other panelists and guests um
so we
were all staying at the same hotel i had
drinks with them afterwards uh really
fun and that actually has happened to me
a number of times on bill's show
where i connected with john mcwhorter on
the show i've connected with different
people who are co-panelists on the show
it used to be that bill
would host a cocktail party for everyone
uh every week where there's like a cast
party and then friends of the show would
just show up now they stopped doing that
with covid sad
but the vibe was really positive uh
there there were a couple of things i
will confess to you that i wanted to get
in that i wasn't able to get in yeah
they were kind of shorter segments they
were shorter segments because they got
uh consumed by the oscars
oscars aftermath there's a lot on that
so
um so i i did talk about uh
radicalization due to automation as
connected to the loss of manufacturing
jobs
but i wanted to make a point about uh
greater empathy for boys and men as uh
supplementing that um where it seemed to
me that
uh framing everything
as like a zero-sum game between genders
is a
disaster
and that helping
women helps men helping men helps women
uh particularly when talking about boys
and girls yep cohesive relationship yeah
but you know the conversation didn't
really take that turn because
um he kind of uh
you know talked about
men
relatively perfunct really in part
because he knew i wanted to talk about
it so i didn't want to
all of a sudden start going down
um like this logical chain so i kind of
hit the automation radicalization point
and who were the other two panelists it
was laurent laura codis who was an
author and then laura coates who's a
cnn legal
analyst and then the other person is
nicole pearl roth is a cyber security
reporter
for the new york times and she had all
this very fascinating information about
our vulnerabilities so that's what the
one-on-one segment was about um both of
them are great backstage yeah the two
questions that you guys covered was do
you think merrick garland the attorney
general is taking too long to press
criminal charges related january 6th the
other conversation was more so about
judge jackson nomination for supreme
court and everything that kind of goes
along with that but for the january 6
hearings
the house select committee investigation
is coming up
what are your predictions do you think
anything's going to come from that
i have low expectations yeah honestly so
to the extent that something happens i'd
be positively surprised i completely
agree and then like
the most interesting discussion there
was that the initial election of course
is always the primary election but
specifically this
coming election amongst the republican
party is going to be major and they were
pressing you about who you think is
going to be running in the republican
party
but we see a lot a lot of unenthused of
course democrats which was discussed
mostly because yeah there's a 17-point
enthusiasm yes between republicans and
democrats right now that that was crazy
so all eyes are going to be on the
republican party and the last time the
gap was this big i think 60 seats swung
hands right now the
democratic majority i want to say is
something like 10 seats
i feel like for young voters too this is
very overwhelming because if you're a
registered democrat
and you're kind of just observing what's
happening happening within the
republican party
how do you see that playing out within
the republican party and people maybe
who aren't trump loyalists
how they can kind of make it well i mean
that's part of this too is that the
democrats ran against trump for four
years yeah sort of reasonable he was the
president
uh and then now republicans are running
against beyond the democrats and it's
very hard for by the democrats to run
against trump because trump's nowhere on
the ballot yes people are generally very
very upset about what's going on in the
country
inflation being probably the biggest
day-to-day problem
so we all expect
republicans to have a very very good
november
and the enthusiasm is much higher among
republicans than democrats
um so
you know i think that's going to be
borne out i mean it's going to be a very
tough cycle
and so the the
question
really is where does that go in 24 in my
opinion yeah like i feel like 22 is
essentially
uh written uh you know not to say i mean
we'll still be involved in various races
in 22 and try and make a difference uh
in heck i mean there's some primaries
coming up too in june um and as anyone
who follows this podcast knows like a
lot of the action is in the primaries
because the generals are so
uncompetitive yep
so for you
thinking about like 2020 and how you
coming in and type you up
was
was so different for young people first
of all you were kind of the first
candidate who really talked about tech
and was also the first candidate who
really you didn't seem like a party
loyalist by any means
yes
maybe that's a biased opinion but
i think also just seeing yeah these
unenthused democrats
it seems the perfect opportunity for
something new to come in something
that's exciting at the end of the day
there's a lot of ties between
entertainment and politics unfortunately
and it often feels like right now that
people are kind of
taking a step back from all the
craziness that's happened with within
the 2020 election and that something new
and exciting needs to come in so how do
you see even like
with this craziness within the
republican party and who is going to win
there how do you see a third party
coming in
republican who's going to begin running
against trump or the new exciting third
party which one is it or both
kind of both it's just more so so the
unenthused democrat voters there's going
to be a lot of attention on the
republican party like we just discussed
but it's kind of the perfect entry for a
third party and how you came in so
strong within the 2020 election
basically a complete outsider how do you
see a third party coming in with a
strong impact and honestly getting a lot
of young voters who we can talk about
this too there's a ton of young
independent voters well so this is the
question jules which is so whenever
anyone thinks third party what they
think of is presidential yeah
and in some ways that's logical because
that's what they are familiar with yes
you know they remember
maybe
um
i i don't know who they remember i mean
maybe it's ralph nader or
pro if they're a little bit older
and
that's because when third-party
candidates run locally
you never hear about them and it's
almost impossible for them to compete
now
so that this is the quandary that we're
in which is that you'd like third-party
candidates to be able to compete in more
environments but it turns out their
greatest opportunity is the presidential
or national because you have enough
resources where someone could
potentially get a message out that's not
contained within either the two parties
now a lot of folks look at that and also
say well the stakes are much higher in
the national because
in this case let's say if you were to
run third party
you might increase the chances of trump
winning something along those lines
so i agree with your premise that
there's going to be something new that
emerges and the question is is it within
the republican primary yep and i think
there's a good chance that something new
is going to emerge in the republican
primary is it enough to upset the
dynamics and defeat trump
tbd
um i'm somewhat skeptical because i
think the
both the prime the republican primary
electorate and the energy at this time
will favor trump uh significantly and i
have talked to to their point about bill
maher asking me questions about this i
have people who are considering running
republicans for president of the united
states
and that they're making the same
evaluation i'm describing which is like
hey
um is
is is there a path to victory uh in
the republican primary um the folks that
i can clearly see running in the
republican primary are people that
frankly are willing to accept low
prospects for victory yeah perhaps
someone like chris christie who's like i
have nothing to lose like let's just do
this thing
so let's just do this
you know like is something like that
going to run totally um the the major
question uh uh is like will there be a
figure like around desantis or larry
hogan who is much more political
uh capital um to both compete against
trump um but also more to lose yeah uh
will there be a new younger figure like
a will hurd who we had on the podcast
um so that's variable one is that will
there be a new figure from within the
republican uh primary field number two
is will there be a democratic primary
and if so will there be someone new that
emerges there
and then number three is like maybe they
come from outside of the two parties uh
as an independent
via the forward party or a unity ticket
one of the fun things about being andrew
yang during this time
is that
is that to the extent that there's
anyone in any of these categories uh
they're interested in talking to me
because they think i can help they think
i can help with young people in
particular yeah for sure they know i
have very very relevant experience
probably more relevant than just been
anyone else
in the country because like you know i'm
one of the
few people who've been through a version
of this process yeah
so it's been fun because i talk to them
and
i get a sense of them some of them i
like a lot and are
genuine to me
um
patriots or someone who just want to do
something positive
uh when i was coy when bill asked it's
like oh snap like how many of these
people have i talked to that actually
like i'm allowed to divulge yeah they
were really trying to pick at you like
let us know the answer is you know like
i guess you know i i can't divulge any
of them because you know like none of
them have
made any plans and even to me it's not
like they tell me like hey i'm doing
this thing like that they'll say
something like i'm seriously considering
so you know what are you necessarily
nothing confirmed
anyway
um
[Music]
right right now to me the major
variables whether joe decides to run for
president again and whether there is a
democratic primary kamala certainly does
not clear the field so
uh the the things i'm hearing from
people or that
that joe apparently wants to run again
so there's that there are people around
him that are
less uh enthusiastic
but but there are also some
um some signs of health issues shall we
say that that might make it such that
for sure not necessarily we're going to
run and that that's
i mean let me say on the record
uh i hope that joe does not run again um
i think i think he may choose to run
again because he feels he's the only one
that can defeat trump if trump becomes
the republican nominee i think the odds
of joe
running again go up because joe will say
like i'm the only one we can defeat
trump i've done it once
um but i just don't think it's good for
the country for uh for us to have an 82
year old president being sworn in and if
you do have an 82 year old president
being sworn in then this time you know
like we should frankly expect him not to
complete his term and to have a vice
president who were essentially electing
president
which is is that really the play i mean
maybe i mean if if there was a right but
never ideal
yeah
and and then and this is a tough thing
to say out loud but it's like it'd be
very hard for joe to be like hey i'm
going to run again and my vice president
pick is not going to be kamala harris
because i can sense that a lot of you
are concerned about her being the next
president
um so it's very hard for him to make a
change there
but it is also the case that kamala
pulls
poorly
and i i think if if that were the
ticket then people would look and say
we're essentially electing kamala
desantis is interesting because
what what i observe on social media he
seems to have a similar like rallying
behind him not to the extent of trump
but there's like on a smaller scale a
similar energy not not by no means as
kind of toxic as the trump area but he's
someone who if was running against trump
i would see be like the strongest
prospect dude
yeah do do you think he's gonna move
forward with that if he a lot of people
predict he will run against trump why
would you think he he wouldn't
one i heard he was telling donors a
little while ago that he's not going to
run against trump so it could be that he
changed his mind
yes you know straight up answer
that's a pretty straight up answer yeah
uh
well the the other thing is you look at
it just from a risk reward iran's pretty
young yes um if he sits this one out
then he's still the heir apparent coming
in next time and then he'd be you know
the savior and
uh he can wait a cycle you know it's
like his downsides to running against
trump are really potentially significant
because then it's a war for the base
trump is excellent at
um
painting someone in a negative light
for sure so it's just the risk reward
doesn't seem to work
um
though i will quote a republican
that
uh i respect and i agree with he said
that anyone who
says that they won't run against trump
shouldn't ever be president because if
you ever want to be president then
you're you're not as
like calculating about it you're just
like look i think country needs me i'm
ready to go let's do it instead of being
a political calculation be like yeah
i'll sit this one out because you know i
don't want to go to war with trump um i
liked that perspective yeah wait that's
that's very interesting actually but but
uh you know we're talking about
politicians like do they think like that
i mean they do think very much in terms
of their political fortunes i think the
smart political thing for ron to do is
just sit it out
[Music]
do you know you get a different netflix
depending on which country you're
streaming from so netflix literally
hides thousands of shows and movies from
you based on your location now you could
get mad about this because they're
increasing their prices and so you could
cancel your subscription in protest or
you could be smart about it and get
expressvpn like we do so
you may not know that what's on netflix
in your country is completely different
from someone in the uk or japan what
they have on theirs if you use
expressvpn you can control which country
you want netflix to think you're in so
expressvpn has over 90 countries to
choose from so every time i run out of
stuff to watch i just change my country
up and i can switch to another country
and unlock new shows and here's the best
part it's not just for netflix you can
use expressvpn to unlock a show on other
streaming services too hulu or apple tv
or you name it expressvpn is also super
fast and works on your phone laptop even
smart tvs so you can watch your shows on
big screens with zero buffering so
here's the deal we want you to stop
paying full price for streaming services
that don't give you all the shows they
have get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com
yang don't forget to use our link so you
can get three extra months of expressvpn
free that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash yang expressvpn.com
yang
[Music]
also something with the bill maher
conversation that i found really
interesting because they were such short
segments you didn't get really to
elaborate on but
you guys were talking yeah yes
i know no but like this was so
interesting so you guys were talking
about how like uh judge jack jackson was
under a ton of scrutiny for defending
people but she was a public defender you
know she was
assigned these things
and you were talking about how
america is so so polarized you're you're
just on a team and
i really want to talk about that more
because if a rule goes against your team
you ignore it or write it off
and
i want to kind of elaborate on that
because i think there's a huge
discussion there amongst young people in
independent politics regarding
especially social media today and how it
just intensifies every aspect of human
nature and that's a huge aspect of human
nature that we're seeing unfold over the
past few years oh yeah i think uh
i think people who are
arguing for principle in the rule of law
like are just uh you know
um more and more getting drowned out by
people who look at that stuff and be
like wait a minute you know it's like
um let's just everyone seems more and
more hypocritical nowadays you know it's
like tougher and tougher
uh i get that i think for young people
too when i was campaigning for president
i would say this young people would be
like look like we've set your generation
up with a bill of goods and if i were
you i'd be very angry or very sad uh and
i apologize on behalf of everyone who
came before you that we're leaving you
such an awful mess
um so if that's young people's
experience which i think is pretty fair
and then be like hey but follow the
rules
then it's like
there's a little bit like well
should i be following these rules you
speak it of because you know like that
you haven't exactly set us up
for good things
uh and there's like this very very thin
network
of uh institutions trying to keep like
the rules in place
um and then we can see the rules are
being broken all around us i mean i
could use the person that popped into my
mind was actually crypto
first thing
is just breaking all the rules in
various ways then you look at it and be
like well wait a minute like you know
what like what what do we like what does
this mean what do we do here
um
so
uh i i think it's one reason why
third-party politics would be so
interesting to young people i think i
saw something where 70 percent don't
really like either the democratic or the
republican party
um now it could be that par this group
may just not be very into parties in
general um but
uh i i believe that there is a massive
need to be filled there both the
democratic and republican party are just
really old in the tooth kind of like you
know aged establishment brands like i'd
love for there to be like this new fresh
awesome
uh type of politics that includes young
people and they feel like they're a part
of and take ownership of um that maybe
gets us away from this like you know
this
tit for tat back and forth
i'm not even back and forth you know my
sense of things are on young people you
could i should ask you this
is that i don't think that um that folks
who have let's say liberal or
progressive views are necessarily like
clashing with
um like their counterparts on the other
side on a daily basis i think it's more
that there's like this consistent set of
messaging that goes in a particular
direction it's kind of own worlds
yeah yeah you've got like an echo
chamber going yes and then there are
people who are within that echo chamber
that are like you know like maybe i
don't agree with like that
or maybe like for sure a little far like
a little like i that that's my my sense
that you know that that there are a lot
of people just don't feel included
so yeah as of 2019 just over a third of
gen z would consider themselves to be
politically independent and there was
kind of there was about 10 to 12 percent
that just yeah
didn't say they were independent or
democrat or republican but a big thing
that comes towards young people who do
talk about independent politics on
social media is a lot of um a big
left-wing term is this enlightened
centrist term and always aligning yeah
identifying as an independent with being
a centrist
for on the record can you explain the
difference there
yeah i think uh independent to me is
like look i i don't fall within party
orthodoxy yes and like all these
policies
um centrist is like a bit more kind of
wishy-washy with like whatever direction
you want to take i would split it down
the middle
uh and
independents come in all shapes and
sizes and beliefs and and everything
else so imagining that all independents
are
centrists or moderates i don't think is
correct i work with some people who are
very very left like very
very very left who consider themselves
independents i know a lot of
libertarians who consider themselves
independents who are you know probably
you'd think on the other side of the
spectrum which i think the spectrum is
overblown
um so
you know even me it's like you know it
was interesting about me too jules that
like i had a vision that would be a
significant departure from the way we're
doing things and some people thought
it's like oh
like
it seems awfully quick progressive even
though i never
like outright said that yeah like you
know it's like it like would it help
people who don't have a lot yes like you
know in my mind that's kind of the goal
um but
uh i i've concluded that you're not
going to be able to get those things
done and this is something i've thought
a fair amount about because you know i
have a lot of friends who are in the
like what you'd consider the left lane
the progressive camp yep and what what
they do and
in my opinion we're aligned on our
desires for a lot of good things to
happen
um now their plan is to take over the
democratic party and then like make all
these good things happen uh and uh like
i i see two massive problems with that
plan uh number one i don't think taking
over the democratic party is actually in
the cards because there's like this
massive entrenched set of interests that
are gonna want to keep the democratic
party in a
particular lane and you know the media's
part of in the rest of it so that stuff
you could probably figure out a lot of
corruption baked in honestly a lot of
insurance interests and the second thing
is uh i don't think the democratic party
is going to be in a position to be able
to make uh big things happen um for
quite some time
uh you know like you have to see right
now this is the high water mark of
democratic power for at least a while
uh you know very very lucky to get a 50
50 split the senate turns out
um
uh so
you know like so you got like two
massive problems if you're trying to
make things happen big things happen
there are other structural problems too
like now we have these cascading
deficits and inflation's out of control
and some of the things you want to do
like would require uh spending money
which
you know like uh i'm much more open to
than like you know like a lot of folks
so that there are all these structural
problems uh and so to me like the smart
thing to do at this point would be to
try and reorient american politics and
have
like not this two-party system that i do
not think will deliver for anyone the
only thing it's going to deliver is uh
is madness
[Laughter]
yeah we're seeing that
so that that's like the but i mean i
mean anyone who takes a look at um you
know my latest book i mean you know the
goals i have uh are
the same as they've been
i think now like i see the path as being
very different politically than i would
have imagined it um and for for me this
is like uh like learning and adaptation
you know yeah well
this was like fascinating to me it was
also around 2019 a study by pew research
is that
basically there's just a movement from
gen z democrats and republicans coming
to a more unified stance on politics so
even on issues like 52 percent of gen z
republicans want the government to be
more involved in solving social issues
compared to only 23 percent of boomers
within the republican party so even just
within the party there's these crazy
generational differences also only 18 of
gen z republicans believe that humans
are not intensifying climate change
while it was 42 of boomers for example
just these crazy differences within the
party that it does feel more like
these generational changes why like
these
gen z people in the republican party or
gen z people in the democratic party
aren't even aligning on the same things
like you said actually on bill maher
it's more so just a team people a lot of
the times can't even break down what
does this party stand for anymore it's
truly just an ideology at this point and
it's just an energy that you flock to
that causes a ton of polarization online
because as soon as you hear democrat or
as soon as you hear republican you are
just boxing that person into
a certain energy and just not at all
like considering what they're saying and
when in reality there's a very unified
stance on the issues
yeah that's so profound where if you
talk to a young republican that they
they want
uh to help fight climate change and make
positive social things happen or with
the government be a part of that so if
you can try and build those bridges and
make common ground as opposed to just
getting separated into
uh these tribes then you can make real
progress that's why the reorientation is
so important young people join us make
it uh let's make it happen so the the
thing that that i i commented
uh to to someone earlier is that at this
point no matter what you're for
like this system's not going to give it
to you you know what i mean like if
again unless it's madness
so seriously um so i i but i think for
young people to participate in the
reorganization of our politics is a must
like if you're a young person listening
to this do you really think that it's
going to be the democratic part of the
republican party it's going to like
solve some of these problems are getting
worse and worse and have been for
decades under their watch
the fact is that neither party
pays a real long-term meaningful price
for either the problems getting worse or
even losing a race because it just the
ball goes back and forth between the two
of them polarization is just busy work
you need genuine competition you need
more third parties and you've been
conditioned everyone's been conditioned
to be like oh third parties can't work
and then you ask yourself well why is
that it's all because the two parties
shut them out of every
major uh you know like poll or race uh
in these districts so we have to evolve
to
uh ranked choice voting and nonpartisan
open primaries give everyone a shot new
parties would emerge young people would
have a better chance at leadership it'd
be great yeah because you also point out
the uk has five parties germany has
seven parties sweden has eight parties
and so if one party goes crazy let's say
whether it's either republicans or
democrats it's not an existential threat
to the entire system and i i think it's
just crazy we don't like you've
definitely touched on it before but we
don't talk about enough how even george
washington was considered an independent
and actively spoke against the two-party
system that's rarely ever talked about
in schools
and just that point alone like i'm like
that's epic and the fact that we don't
talk about that foundation that was set
for the country and how it completely
went the opposite direction yeah
you guys are real idiots to have this
this bizarro duopoly in place
bizarre no it's true no seriously or the
other thing that uh you know another
great american president abraham lincoln
won the white house with 39.8 percent of
the vote in a four-candidate race he was
essentially a third-party candidate
on the brand-new republican party that
had just materialized as a northern
anti-slavery party
uh so when you think about like in our
nation's history some of our greatest
leaders like they wouldn't be like
democrat republican and
when he ran for office again he
had a unity ticket where he was the
republican president
presidential candidate and the vice
president was a democrat yes so you know
can you imagine these things happening
today like like the greatest leaders
uh in the country's history would be
shocked at where we are right now and
it's also like trump really took over
the term the silent majority during 2020
he which was originally coined by
richard nixon but trump kind of made it
seem more aligned with the republican
party the real silent majority to me yes
are young independents that takes up a
huge margin of the voters and young
people and those these are the people
who don't feel like they can speak up a
lot online because what does well in
algorithms are these extreme takes that
provoke extreme emotions whether they
are good or bad and kind of you know
this middle ground
take isn't what algorithms are it's not
feeding into them that's one reason why
you're so important jules thank you
thank you the middle ground jules tur
pack following her on your favorite
all these plugs all these plugs but to
me it's just what we see online is kids
are online more hours per day than
they're
honestly conversating with people in
person and so what the parties seem like
online the democratic party
the words that align and you don't have
to agree are kind of woke and idealist
and the republican party is often seems
like conspiracy theorists and often
devil's advocates so they the the
republican party online the extremists
often like whatever the left is saying
will oppose it completely no matter how
much it aligns with them because in the
reality like i was saying earlier we see
a more unified stance on politics
amongst young people it's just not being
represented online but when that's all
you're being fed through the algorithms
it can seem
like everyone's on these extreme sides
but it's a small percent
of voters that are truly on the extreme
so
it's been evident like we said george
washington made it obvious that he
didn't believe in a two-party system and
social media and these algorithms just
further intensify again what happens in
human nature and it's just clear right
now that this two-party system is not
what we need at all and it's just
how we're avoiding everything that we
need to get done because of this
bickering back and forth like i said a
few minutes ago it just feels like busy
work and we're not actually talking
about things we need to get done because
just this tribalism back and forth yeah
i i completely agree and let me say too
you know like
i like some of the things that various
democrats have proposed in congress over
this past period you know if you ask me
who i line up with more
uh like right now the republican party
doesn't even have a platform last i
checked um but this
system is really just like it's not
working for anybody
um so
that's one of the
the real lessons that that i've taken
from this past period of time and i do
think we're in the you know final
whatever it
is seven months of uh you know seven
months
of democrats having control of
government i mean nothing's gonna get
done uh starting in november
um and our institutional
uh
trusts
and credibility is just you know
dropping dropping dropping
uh it's it's fun trying to build the
next generation of institution sometimes
i mean you know it's like i'm i'm
someone who
uh
i'm saddened by the the state of the
country and the state of the world um
but
you know like it it's great being able
to work with people like you and you
know trying to give give folks a home
i also feel just again because what we
see online a lot of young people feel
like it's easy to tune out of the
current political system because it
feels like it doesn't suit you or
doesn't support you
um
things like open primaries are an
obvious thing in the short term and also
the long term to continue to root for
especially for young voters who are
these independents like what are things
like assad open primaries and aside from
it that you can actively be pushing for
uh right choice voting would be the
biggest win yes it's like an
anti-extremism change in voting it also
gives you the spoiler effect the entire
like you're going to ruin it it's like
well just it's all right choice voting
if you really care and the the fact is
most people of both parties democrats
and republicans don't like competition
it's one reason why 90 of seats are now
gerrymandered to be uncompetitive so
then you say hey rank choice voting it
allows new perspectives to emerge like
no one's like oh sign me up um i mean
people are like sign me up but democrats
republicans in power are not like sign
me up because if you're an elected
official that one in a given system you
don't want the system to change if
you're a consultant it's like oh this
introduces uncertainty
so this is up for to people like the
folks listening to this to say look rank
choice voting is a win
it's a win for everyone uh it's uh well
it's a win for the public
um the only people that it's not a win
for are
extremists exactly well
we don't want them to win anymore
they've had their time
over the past few decades
how was your stress level
mine is never particularly great
and people don't always realize that
physical symptoms like headaches and
teeth grinding and even digestive issues
can be indicators of stress and let's
not forget about doom scrolling sleeping
too little sleeping too much
under eating or overeating these are all
stress stuff now i'm proud to say this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy
and i've used better help personally a
bunch of different ways um in terms of
what i'm coping with but stress is a big
one because it shows up in so many
different ways and in a world that's
telling you to do more or sleep less and
grind more
this is a friendly reminder to take care
of yourself and better help has online
therapists and personal counseling
sessions that you can talk about
anything online 24 7. it's amazing so
how it works you go online get matched
with a therapist that's right for you
and you get access to them via text or
video chat whenever you want at your
convenience and you can do it as many
times a month as you like it is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy so you can give it a
try and see how online therapy can help
lower your stress this podcast is
sponsored by better help forward podcast
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
yang so that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash yang
[Music]
this all kind of ties into
something that the washington post
actually covered last week regarding
uh meta facebook paid a gop firm to
demean tick tock so they went after you
jules yeah yeah they went after me
honestly it's okay and we can talk about
that but
it's interesting because um
mark zuckerberg was
often like critiqued by the washington
post throughout this article too it's
like what side is he on he donated to a
ton of democratic politicians he's a
democrat yeah
but reality is who knows most people
don't really know at the end of the day
mark zuckerberg is uh what's called a
zuckerbergian yeah yeah yeah for himself
for sure
for himself
you know
like a meta booster yeah so facebook
parent company meta is paying one of the
biggest republican consulting firms in
the country called targeted victory to
orchestrate a nationwide campaign
seeking to turn the public against
tick-tock and this was actually
pretty crazy work by taylor loren says a
lot of journalists today aren't really
actually on the platform or or they'll
browse it this is something she had to
be on the platform often to
really identify so it was months ago she
realized that in like uh local
newspapers that met well she didn't know
was met at the time but there were these
stories planned about tick tock
regarding trends like slap a teacher
trend and schools were literally being
shut down because of these trends and
these scares
and she realized like this is not a
trend on tick tock there was maybe one
viral video and that doesn't constitute
a trend there's not thousands of videos
with it so she started following this
and was able to figure out that um just
talking to local newspapers and also
the meta was planting like op-eds with
top targeted victory about the platform
and mostly because
tick-tock is met as big biggest
competitor we've talked about in past
podcasts that the entire gen z
demographic is moving over to that
platform instagram recently lost active
users for the first time ever mostly
jen's ears and
kind of just yeah zuckerberg going to
great lengths
in order to
put meta on top has been crazy
yeah that's really messed up
a little bit and taylor was talking
about you see this a lot in politics but
never before really in the social media
realm with business so if i had won the
white house i was going to go to war
with zuckerberg truly because
what's good for
facebook i'm going to call it facebook
oh yeah don't give them that respect
[Laughter]
what's good for facebook is not good for
america it's not good for humanity it's
not good for sanity
uh so i i spoke to a political scientist
barbara walter a few weeks ago on the
podcast and she said that facebook is
essentially negative correlated with
functioning democracy around the world
you saw that where it's like if facebook
shows up in a country then they
backslide
direct correlation
like an anti-democracy
company
uh so
uh so i was going to go to war with
zuckerberg uh and the gang um they don't
have
uh any interest at heart except for
uh
metta's
uh
profitability um and
um zuckerberg's uh
increasingly dissociated view of the
future
for sure where i've heard that he just
hangs out in the metaverse more than he
hangs on the real world and look you
know like i'm as big a fan of uh aspects
of
virtual worlds as anyone else but uh you
know i'm gonna suggest that that's
probably not healthy
so
so i hope they pay a price for this but
the problem is
here here i mean there's so many
problems but here yeah we could talk
about this for two hours
so so it's like what price could
meta facebook zuckerberg pay
like you would need a functioning
government yeah you know you need
someone to be like okay like this is uh
beyond the pale it sounds like kelly
lorenz really freaking hunted this stuff
down too yeah
crazy good story seriously yeah nice
journalism yeah um so
uh
number one people would be like oh
everyone should stop using them it's
like well you know these social media
platforms are
ingrained in our lives so it's like
abandoning them now
personally i'm not against you
abandoning them honestly
everybody so if you
you know like you you log off i mean
that that's fine but it's unrealistic
for a lot of people it's unrealistic for
any business because you have to try and
reach people
so that's not a thing and then it'd be
like government
um
action but our government when they do
bring these social media leaders and
they yell at them about uh things that
are unrelated to
uh you know that they're kind of
anti-competitive practices i mean
they're quasi monopolies
so
uh so the fact is facebook can play fast
and loose in this way and i mean we've
seen it over and over again they'll just
keep on doing things
that are beyond the panel and they don't
pay a meaningful price completely and so
their biggest thing was that employees
within the firm targeted victory worked
you know to the extent there is a price
being paid right now what it's that
a lot of cool people don't want to work
at facebook anymore that is true that is
true very true
and
so their biggest target during these
articles was mostly so these trends kind
of just painting tick tock as you know
about bad player in the game because
they often feel like they get unfair
press and in regards to us talking right
now like yeah there's there definitely
is kind of a focus on uh meta well not
facebook instagram and these social
media conversations especially regarding
youth well-being they're definitely a
main target amongst congress and
everyone um so they kind of want to
paint someone else in a different light
and you see lately zuckerberg has been
making a lot of independent media
appearances which he had never ever done
before he's been
very odd very like calculated it's all
it's been like
in the past two months three or four of
them that
and before never has he ever he would
get on like good morning america here
and there but obviously that's super
high production and everything and these
were pretty high produced as well though
lex freeman claimed that there was no
like censoring beforehand that they
didn't look over the questions or
anything like that but
i will say so their focus in regards to
um
criticizing tick tock was regard in
regards to china and selling a lot of
these kids data and all of that being
obtained by china
but what's interesting to me and i
actually did a video on this week and a
half ago and i don't know how this got
pushed on the tick tock platform so it
was me criticizing tik tok on the tick
tock platform which sounds contradictory
but you can go into why i did that and
it's sitting around like 800k views
right now
and the video was about how
kids focus today much in part due to all
social media but tic tocs the holy grail
of this is just completely declining and
you actually had an interview with the
author of stolen focus which was really
good and i suggest people go listen to
that too but the biggest problem really
is yeah the immediate short-term effect
of tick-tock is this complete stolen
focus and this device you have in your
hand is basically a paradox of choice
device where whatever you're doing you
feel like something can be more
stimulating to you on an app like
tick-tock because it is so well curated
to you and it's a bottomless feed unlike
any other platform before that feed is
completely bottomless but let's say
and it's really rewiring kids brains and
i could go on about this for an hour
that's the real problem but let's say
tic toc gets shut down
these other platforms we're still in the
attention economy and meta is trying to
copy that with reels and youtube is
trying to copy that with shorts that's
the real
immediate problem and all these
platforms are trying to do the same
thing and then some with virtual reality
and everything like that so
yeah they're going to this data angle
but
it's clear i mean obviously it's for
business intentions but
yeah yeah it'd be one thing if facebook
was all of a sudden doing all of these
like massive
uh
remediation measures themselves yes but
they're not
no not at all not at all and then wall
street journal actually
posted
a piece on saturday and it was tick tock
brain explained why some kids seem
hooked on social video feeds it was
going into a lot of what i talked about
in the video as well
and i just want to read this intro
because i think it's really powerful so
it's like remember the good old days
when kids just watched youtube all day
now that they binge on 15 second tick
tocks those youtube clips seem like pbs
documentaries many parents tell me their
kids can't sit through feature length
films anymore because to them movies
feel painfully slow others have observed
their kids struggling to focus on
homework and reading a book forget about
it what is happening to kids brains and
then goes into like the adhd
conversations and this article is also
super fascinating on the topic i don't
think i got worried about this uh
facebook meta coverage about demeaning
tick tock because yeah it puts a lot of
focus then back on meta and there are a
lot of things to critique about tick
tock and i noticed on my video then that
was getting a lot of traction and
response that a lot of positive
responsive kids being like i'm getting
off this app for today this was like a
reality check and it's true i'm deleting
this app for the week i need a break
but then i started to see comments after
this article came out a few days after
like oh was this planted by meta or
something
so then it kind of also takes
responsibility again back off of
tick-tock when in reality there needs to
be
a lot of discussion about how it's
rewiring kids brains and we need kids to
be able to focus in order to make change
in the future and like you know um
people need to have like a long-term
focus and vision a lot of the times now
when you say oh in the future i want
this to happen whether it's within
change or like independent politics a
lot of people are like oh like next year
no like the future can be like a five to
ten year timeline and like you have to
work continuously at something to be
able to actually achieve it and we're
seeing a lot of that being lost within
kids right now yeah i someone said to me
this week that uh they think that it's
gonna be up to gen x to fix all these
tech issues uh and the the argument was
that gen x actually remembers a time
before the technology and then remembers
the time after technology for sure and
uh and so we're we're not luddites but
we actually do remember the time before
and i said wow and i thought of the gen
xers i know who were running for office
um it's bad though you know like that
there are other societies that have
taken much more
um protective measures uh but here in
the u.s we just have so little faith in
government
that uh we just throw any restriction on
as freedom of speech let's say here's an
example something i would recommend
yes i'll tear it please is that that i
would say hey if you're under 18 uh your
social media apps don't work between
uh 11 p.m and 7 a.m for sure eight hours
without it yeah because china's doing
that and it's like a collective
experience because right now in kids if
if you're a parent and you tell your kid
oh you can't have your phone after 9 pm
there's this like fomo feeling fear of
missing out but no one's done you're not
seeing anything you're like yeah am i
missing something what are my friends
doing um
social media stuff is breaking out left
and right like breaking news and it is
like a fear of missing out i i feel that
at the age of 24 like at every like i'm
looking at you
wait wait wait what'd you say no just
like you're like you feel like missing
at the age of 24 which is that i mean we
all feel that because yes you're
standing in line and you're just like oh
what's going on in the world yeah
you can't just stand in line it's a very
exhilarating collective experience when
like uh yeah news is breaking even this
morning and we can talk about like elon
musk and twitter it was cool to see
everyone's reactions in time and like
how shocking it was and it's maybe not
as stimulating if you're a day or two
late
like stuff like that it can feel like
you're missing out on um especially in
the worlds we're in where you kind of
like want to hop on be knowing things
like as they're happening
and a lot of people are kind of
critiquing oh well tech talks like
inserting 10 minute videos onto their
feeds those i've seen people try to do
those they're not doing well the
platform is not built for 10 minute
videos
it's crazy so to the point of what
you're saying yeah the hours and we've
discussed this before but i think it's
really important for everyone to know
because a lot of people write it off
because oh china's doing it china's just
as intimidated by their tech companies
as the us is about our big tech
companies that's one of the tough things
too it's like yeah like uh china does
some very very bad things yes but but
just because china makes a policy
decision doesn't automatically mean it's
like the wrong one exactly
you know it's like
let's say they get you know 20 of them
right 80 them wrong you'd still look at
it and be like well which which one is
this
yeah because i did coverage on like the
four things that china is doing for um
kids on doing which is tick tock's
equivalent in the country people just
come like wrote it off because it was
china they're just like oh i'm not doing
that like
and just to quickly add for everyone
else the four things that china is doing
for kids so
yeah so it's from 10 p.m to 6 a.m
kids under 16. it's not 18 aren't
allowed on the app so just like they
just don't have access to the app
every i think it's like 15 to 20 videos
um there's a five to ten second pause
kind of get them out of that hypnosis
that is so easy to get into on tick tock
of course like
duh um
if you're on the app for more than 40
minutes straight kicks you off i don't
know the duration for how long it kicks
you off but you get kicked off
that that seems reasonable 40 minutes
straight on a social media app not
really a need and the other thing is so
in america the algorithm is very
catered to your subconscious mind and
your interests anything you're giving
watch time to whether it's good or bad
the algorithm just really caters to
exactly what you give watch time to
in
china they're infiltrating that a little
bit not not in a bad way um but to kids
under 16 i'm not sure how it is for
adults they're pushing more edutainment
stem content so you know fun
learning physics equations yeah and
right now on tick tock and the wall
street journal actually did a video
series on this like a year or two ago um
they made like a couple thousand bots on
the app and kind of gave them different
interests
and assign them those interests and when
videos would come up with those certain
hashtags would watch those videos longer
someone um one of the bot not someone
one of the bots they aren't people yet
um one of the bots had like an interest
of depression and like sadness
um after just like 45 minutes the
algorithm
figured it out and like every two videos
were like a depressing
video
that's like what some kids are living in
i remember when i was on tumblr in
middle school
so dramatic my my tumblr name was like
finding color in this black and white
world something like that
yeah like no reason to be sad but tumblr
like anyone who's on that app knows that
it was the first app to really like
romanticize mental illness and like
really made kids like put it on
themselves
and but it was of course not to the
extent of tick-tock there wasn't a crazy
algorithm it was just based on who you
followed and like what you curated
yourself tic tac's just feeding you this
content nonstop and
i i can't imagine so many kids that when
you're exploring your identity and like
you know sad boy hours just being
dramatic like you you could have nothing
wrong in your life
and
it's just yeah exploring that side of
life
and these algorithms can just like
completely rewrite your brain to make
you believe a certain thing it's insane
oh jules i'm so glad that you're digging
into these issues uh because for a lot
of older people tick-tock is you know a
bit of a mystery oh for it's for sure
definitely a mystery but it's crazy that
i think the average time spent on it is
like
three to four hours a day for kids
that's a huge chunk of your day it is
hypnotic i i i mean i don't spend time i
was like
are you spending i mean i spent so okay
i mean people probably know this my
experience with the tick tock is making
tick tock videos because my team was
like oh this would be a good idea yeah
it's where people are yeah so i've done
it so i watched enough videos to be like
wow this is well so i remember like
twitter vines over and over again is
what i think of them
and it is hypnotic um i'm proud to say i
have not
actually spent more than you know five
minutes on this wow that's that's
impressive
thank you thank you
andrew yang for president the willpower
to resist
the hypnosis yes this is the kind of
leadership you need
facts
no but
it's crazy and it seems contradicting
contradicting oh why'd you post uh
tic tac video about yeah on tech talk is
where kids are and there's no potential
reach like that app and
i advise everyone go watch that video
and see the comment section like
everyone was just like like i needed to
see this on this app there's no no other
way people probably seen that unless it
was youtube smart yeah
i mean it can seem contradicting
contradicting at face value but
it's just it was just crazy to see how
people were reacting to it too and
talking about their own experience with
they were used to love watching
documentaries and now they can't even
get through a movie or a tv show without
checking their phone every five minutes
like just this weird
like subconscious pool to just like
swipe a few times on tickets i confess
and this is something you know i'm
making me sound a little bit like a
funny daddy but i'm kind of grateful i
came of age when i did no yeah and then
now that all this this stuff has come
online
i'm you know like a dad and chilling yes
no no i think that's important because
even
me like social media didn't come around
till middle school and so i do still
feel like i
remember life before then and yeah like
even like my millennial aged friends
like they decently know what life was
like before they were on my space but
it's just completely different type of
social media
and
it's it's just scary because kids don't
know anything else now and
yeah and there's just this crazy digital
footprint you see a lot of family
channels now and these kids who are
yeah being forced to have their identity
on social media even it's just like
when my mom posts pictures of me
sometimes i'm like mom like ask me like
this is like online like it's it used to
seem like chill and only your friends
and family could see it but
it it all adds up mom jules is famous
now oh no no
not to that extent but i'm like come on
like there's this whole stereotype
everyone to protect you no no it's a
whole stereotype of like the ugliest
pictures of you are on your parents
facebook like that's where they live all
the time but
it adds up when we're already seeing
this compounding digital footprint of
people we've seen it in the past with
cancer cancel culture a few years back
but kids are going to have like yeah
stuff from
they were like five years old online
that their parents posting kids in like
the bath and all this i'm like what are
you doing like this is not okay like
this is the internet and this is
accessible to everyone and it's crazy
[Music]
uh wow you got me fired up jewels i i'll
still take a shot at fixing this stuff
from
please from you know i mean it has to
emanate from dc in my opinion uh well
this was the first time biden addressed
it really stated his state of the union
address he talked about
social media and youth well-being his
focus was a lot on advertisements
which goes hand in hand with data of
course data is important in this but
you know data's not like a sexy thing
that people like to talk about like
when you hear that there's kind of just
like a disconnect you tune out you're
like okay what does that even mean that
seems like such a large conversation
and in in reality um yeah he talked
about advertising but also people
kids don't really have buying power you
see advertisements on nickelodeon
growing up you don't have a card you
can't really make moves on that
it's it's part of the problem but it
yeah it's not the guts of it i get it
and the immediate
clear
situation that's hitting kids in mental
health um is pretty good
in this direction nice job joe
yeah no no yeah for sure yeah no i was
like really pleased to hear that was
even a conversation it was pretty
prominent throughout that i say they
they fight so hard about any sentence in
that state of the union really yeah i
don't know if you all know that probably
super calculated
people are fighting fighting fighting to
get a line a sentence uh and so anything
that makes it in crowded out something
else
um it's it's actually a very positive
sign well
kind of back to this too with this
article and uh how people were saying
this is often something that's done
within politics kind of these planting
of the seed articles what has your
experience been there kind of just like
i i feel like this was very interesting
to young people to really see wow like
this platform i'm on all the time that
has a huge impact on my life is being
targeted by this other platform i'm on
all the time i think
kind of not true that's not trivial by
any means but these things that are
collect again collective experiences
help people
really actualize
that same action on a bigger scale so
like within politics how have you seen
that place it did remind me of
so candidates and campaigns
plant negative stories about opponents
all the time yeah um so in a way it's
like is the fact that facebook then
turned to republican consulting to play
these uh stories about tick tock and
saying i guess they that that
almost makes sense uh you know the fact
that he could get traced back to them i
mean this is like a worst case scenario
for them it's like oh no we didn't want
to get caught
um yeah but it it it's definitely
commonplace in politics
um i'd imagine it's not uncommon in
business if you have a few big players
like are they playing mean against each
other sure i uh
met richard branson a little while ago
and he was telling stories about how
like the major when he started you know
virgin
airline um that like there aren't many
airlines in the uk and like the other
airlines were doing like crazy stuff to
stop him
really like like it was worse than
planning negative stories it was like
just like all sorts of brutal it was
just brutal stuff um so
uh you know i mean business is a very
tough sport um but
uh the fact that
i i think part of the story that's like
if
um
i think the intermediary that
facebook uses part of the problem it's
like hiring the republican firm to trash
it just leaves tick tock it leaves you
with a very very bad taste
it's it's fascinating to me like i could
just like
look into this stuff for hours but on
another note with social media today
we're recording on monday i'm not sure
when it's dropping probably thursday but
um it was announced that elon musk
bought 9.2 percent of shares in twitter
um so a few weeks ago a big tweet that
he put out and my laptop died so i can't
read it word for word but was
asking about twitter's relationship with
freedom of speech and if people feel
like they um are able to utilize their
right there in a good way i think it was
people said no like 70 of people believe
that uh twitter does not super align
with freedom of speech and only uh 30
percent agreed with so
and then elon was talking to people on
twitter again about oh do we need a new
social media platform he that that would
be
a pretty insane move i think i remember
when even tick-tock came out i think i
was like we are at our max with social
media platforms like what void is there
to fill yes freedom of speech is like my
voice is that the next social media
platform trillion dollar idea from
andrew yeah oh gosh
don't give the
don't give the startups your idea there
you go it is
tick
like three second videos
jesus
no but no
yeah
jeez
no but like
even yeah a platform coming that
kind of you know extra helps people
exercise freedom of speech more if it's
the same exact special as a total dud
yes it's a total dud and like people
knew that from the start um of course
you know trump loyalists were running to
the platform and within like a week or
something people just stopped you like
the user base went yeah if you go into a
freaking empty
uh bar do you like stay there
yeah it's like you're getting tired of
like
what maybe it was a good moment people
being like wow this is kind of insane of
us let's move back to where everyone
else is it's more fun collective
experiences are more fun and with like
uh people outside of
this echo chamber so maybe it was a good
moment who knows
but
yeah like
even cr elon creating another platform
and he's someone who's
no no he's not he just put out a
question i think yeah so to mess around
there's no way but yeah there's no way
that's happening and and thank god it
would have been a dumb move but this is
super interesting
um
to i i just find it fascinating i want
to hear your take as well you know i
i've met elon
um
my metric dorsey
um and i i genuinely think that this is
a personal thing
like i think that elon um and jack had
some combos and then uh you know elon
decided to
buy a stake in twitter it's passive he
doesn't have any you know he's also i
can say very much that like
elon's totally over scheduled and has
like other things on his mind yeah it's
kind of just like a statement yeah i
like it and uh you know it seems like a
massive investment but for him i mean
it's like one percent or so of his net
worth like you know and
culturally it's crazy culturally it's
crazy the the fact is twitter
in terms of social media businesses is
not a great business
uh you know it's not its cultural impact
is much much higher
than its economic for sure uh impact
um heck i mean even you know like jack
dorsey stepped away and is now running
square full-time and if you look at
those two businesses square is a much
bigger business
more significant too and um so
i i think this was a relationship thing
personally yeah
so i think twitter like i've i've said
this for the past few years i think
twitter is going to win like the long
game with all these social media pop
it's my fate like there's a lot of bad
on twitter don't get me wrong i'm not
putting it on pedestal
but it's been my favorite platform and i
think there's so many different use
cases for it in terms of
i said this last podcast but it's kind
of what linkedin wishes it could be in
terms of content so i i had the most
singular set of twitter experiences as
so check it out imagine being like a
relatively anonymous guy ran for
president states and then went from our
full whatever 5 000 twitter followers to
1.2 million 200 followers over the
course of i don't know like 15 months 18
months whatever it was
um and
so in that
you know one point uh two million people
um were a lot of people who i'd heard of
or you know in some cases um
uh was a fan of and so when you're crazy
yeah so this is something that i i will
say like it's probably relatively unique
to me
um uh because you can't relate because
people aren't you know but like you just
look up and be like holy [ __ ] like you
know
like rivers cuomo follows me on twitter
now it's like the greatest thing ever
and then you'd be like hey what's up and
so i ended up meeting
a lot of people
this way yes it's crazy
networking yeah yeah and so and then
people would hit me like dm me be like
hey big fan i'd be like oh that's so
nice jeez okay yes yeah so there was
like something very very
uh utilitarian and powerful and positive
um you know the folks who were part of
the yang yang were connecting on twitter
all the time and like i'd meet someone
on twitter and i'd see them at a rally
or an event it's like the greatest thing
ever so like that you know like i i
might have experienced some of those
positive
uh aspects of twitter
um
and when i was running for president and
i was you know between stops in iowa
uh like i was looking for productive
things to do and so it was either
uh use my phone to call people or
use twitter
you know
what's the option twitter
um well i found twitter to be you know
more
more fun because common people because
people i mean you're calling people to
ask for their endorsement yes or are you
calling people for money and none of
those things is that pleasant
[Laughter]
i mean i keep using the word fascinating
but it's just because i love these like
yeah social media culture conversations
and with twitter it's very interesting
because when i was in middle school it
was a prominent platform aside with
instagram everything i said though that
said i think twitter's user base is
shrinking is it or no no i think it's
been growing has it yeah i think this
year yes i'm pretty sure i wish i could
google right now because my laptop said
yeah i'm pretty sure this yes
wait okay wait can i make this point
because it goes with that
so
in high school i i would utilize twitter
same with my peers when i talk about
this too
and in college it's kind of like there
were a few years where twitter died out
and i noticed this in my younger
siblings as well it's kind of like
you make a twitter account it's harder
to navigate because it's not like um
like instagram you know you follow your
friends tic-toc the content comes to you
and you're following a lot of strangers
twitter's a little harder to navigate
when you first make a profile
but
it's where yeah a lot of
professionals are and like as you get to
the end of college and into early
adulthood you start to be more active on
the platform a lot of kids do use it for
like a fandom culture and stands like
you you love your favorite celebrities
or like pop artists or whatever
but it becomes more prominent in like
your early adulthood and like i just
keep seeing so many people flock back to
it and just again it becomes their
favorite platform like it kind of was
when in middle school when you used it
more for humor reasons it's like this
weird cycle with twitter and like you go
back to loving it and
it's just super
um great and like your adulthood but to
the point back to elon and the talk
about freedom of speech
it's going to be interesting to see how
that plays out and what his
kind of hopes are in regards to twitter
and freedom of speech because mark
zuckerberg talked about this on the lex
freeman podcast about
you know lex freeman grilled him about
one of the biggest critiques is
regarding freedom of speech and mark was
like
what would you do it's so easy to
critique that conversation there's a
million different ways but what would
you do and no almost no one has an
answer once you get asked that because
you can see oh this video got taken down
and a lot of these videos are taken down
through ai and even mark zuckerberg got
grilled a few years ago in front of
congress because yeah content moderators
were being paid
um a typical minimum wage but they're
sitting there all day watching looking
at the worst of human nature and losing
their minds literally in therapy
literally so
a human should not have to do that and
so then you have to rely on ai and of
course there's going to be flaws in that
and when you have these crazy click bait
um
headlines whether it's on youtube yeah i
get frustrated when i hear zuckerberg's
response to stuff like that yes it's
like look you're making gajillions of
dollars and your approach to this is
essentially it's like hey we're going to
try and curb the most rancid stuff we
can counter measure leave us alone
um and then part of it's like look man
like you could do bigger things that
probably hurt your bottom line like that
there should be like no
the so the the like what someone said is
uh it's like like the algorithm should
not be feeding into this stuff like
you're profiting from a lot of the these
things and then complaining about it
it's like you know just like turn the
algorithms off
and say that you're not
um
you know like you're just you're not
going to profit from content unless
you're willing to stand by it and then
all of a sudden they'd be like oh snap
like you know
like so it's
it's like if you assume the current
state of affairs then you could be like
oh like what's a person to do but it's
like well you know you're assuming all
these things that are baked into your
business model because they make you
tons of money like if you were to draw
this up from scratch like you you could
do this in very dramatic ways you would
almost certainly make a lot less money
and but like that like that it's it's
funny it's like they're willing to
consider anything but those measures so
do you think
so when you say turn off the algorithms
because right now the algorithms to me
on a lot of these platforms especially
tick tock genuinely feel like it's just
a reflection of your mind and like what
you give attention to and yes humans
tend to flock to kind of these extremes
happy and bad feelings so how do you see
the algorithm like what do you think
well so because right now the algorithm
is programmed to do one thing
maximizing attention yeah it's just like
hey how do i maximize your engagement
and then it's like what will you pay
attention like i can't be blamed yep you
know and
and so you could easily temper that and
just be like hey maybe we're not going
to maximize engagement maybe we're going
to like
you know maybe we'll actually make
programming decisions maybe we'll take
some responsibility maybe we'll do you
know it's like like the the
it so it would make it probably a little
bit less
profitable make it probably less
entertaining and make it less addictive
like a lot of things you could do that
make it less addictive
um
yeah so
uh so i anyway i just feel like
the what can we do response just you
know assumes all these market conditions
what gets interesting there to me though
is like
yeah when they're kind of uh making more
tweaks with the algorithm in regards to
yeah maybe not perfectly
aligning with the extremes that it does
right now i feel like almost it gets
more nitty gritty into the lack of
freedom of speech conversation if
they're being more calculated about
what type of content should be pushed
more or shouldn't be pushed more rather
than oh just what people give more eyes
on because yeah
that is the point so i think this is so
this is the thing that
you know that they're trying to run this
balance which i think at this point it's
like look man it's ridiculous
is that um like look we're not a uh
publisher or a platform yeah you know
it's like we give control it's like you
say it
um and and then part of me is like
you're actually the biggest publisher in
the history of the world yes
you're the biggest publisher taking less
responsibility
so
you know there are all of these uh rules
of the road that i think could be
followed
and
uh does it end up within running into
this strange zone of like well what
what's what's hate speech what's not
what's insanity what's not yeah you know
that threatening was not um
and that's legitimate for them to be
like look
can't have random lowly paid human doing
making that decision we do have ai doing
it they screw up sometimes people get
mad you know like that that's a very
very legitimate conversation yeah that's
more so even uh and even like uh like
i've heard from heads of social media
companies being like look i shouldn't be
making this decision
um and and that's something that i
sympathize with a hundred percent that's
something where you and and for them
what they're doing here's their problem
their problem is like look we're not a
public commons we're a private company
we do whatever the hell we want we don't
even tell you about it we're going to
draw this line here and then you're
happy you're unhappy whatever say lavi
no one can do anything like let's secure
state of affairs what you want is you'd
want them to actually open the kimono
and be like okay here are the guidelines
we're using like like okay can someone
improve on this in some way let's have
like a consortium of
government
ngos media companies and tech figuring
out like how we treat this in a way that
doesn't drive people insane doesn't like
run a file of this and that um but that
that's not something they want to do
because it's like look i'd rather just
get criticized sometimes and keep it
behind the kimono um you know because
there's so much we don't ever find out
about what's going on inside of
facebook and their algorithms because
they don't share the data yeah it's a
beast of a problem because to your point
there yeah we're talking about certain
things are obvious for um
people to put off the platforms where
yeah whether it's violence or whatever
don't need to be seen on the platforms
yeah it gets into
the wishy-washy situations when it's
like can this provoke violence can this
provoke you know mass hysteria yeah and
that's where
where it definitely gets
messy and it's going to be interesting
to see how
um because i think elon replied someone
yeah like uh i don't necessarily agree
with you on this piece of content but i
think deleting it is wrong and of course
that can be true in a lot of instances
but it gets wishy-washy especially with
like yeah all coveted when things maybe
weren't true initially and were
suppressed on platforms or even deleted
and maybe certain things became true and
little little truths within and people
really ran with those as examples um
something i liked that platforms did
were the warnings so it wasn't deleting
the content but people could press on
them reality is
people became numb to those and you
weren't pressing on it and actually
reading the content so it's it's just a
crazy tough problem to attack i think
that was a step in the right direction
though not taking this content down but
we're going to put a warning here that
hey these are some sources where you
might want to flock to instead i thought
that was interesting yeah i got some
warnings on my stuff when i was like
celebrating various political races and
it was like really this race has not
been called
i was like oh sorry yeah i think it's
like keywords or whatever yeah i was
like yeah that race was over
[Laughter]
dang yeah people would run with that too
they're like my stuff got a warning it's
like yeah if you just put covid anything
that says kobe gets a warning no matter
if it's interesting or against
yeah at least that's how it was on
instagram at a point if like you put the
words covered in an instagram story
there was a little warning at the bottom
[Music]
uh so our last discussion item is going
to be this happy
oh good initiation of a union in
staten island
amazon warehouse yes unionized very very
brave uh thank you for doing this for
all of us
can and also just someone over the past
few years so kind of the starbucks union
and all the press around that was the
first
it just feels like there's this uprise
in unions right now and
i would love to hear like your thoughts
on this as well i think a lot of young
people are just getting into the
workforce and like the actual importance
of unions is kind of
something that people are confused about
yeah unions are definitely making um a
comeback after
uh like a multi-decade in a
multi-generational even decline yeah
that there was a i think writ large
there was a point when unions
represented approximately i think i want
to say it's like 40 of the workforce and
then now
wow it's down to like 20 or like it's
gone down half
um or so and unions uh gotten a bad rap
there are excesses associated with
unions but you know what else their
access is associated with
amazon a little bit a little bit um and
and so in the context of something like
amazon the union's a pure good like the
the excesses and unions are frankly more
like uh you know teachers unions and
some other
environments uh in the corporate setting
uh workers are getting exploited uh
very very consistently and so people
being able to come together
uh is a huge win there were massive
pressures against the people who are
trying to organize yes so kudos to them
for standing strong
i'm sure it won't be the last amazon
union because now that other
locations look up and be like wait they
actually did this in a place and yeah
empowered they're going to win some
concessions as well so they're going to
be a lot of eyes on staten island and
the amazon fulfillment center there i
will say that i think staten island is
an appropriate hotbed for this because
there there are a lot of
uh independent minded their people there
who also benefit from unions there are a
lot of cops in
staten island a lot of people who who
are part of these orgs yeah and again
for kind of young people getting to the
workforce and this has been very
empowering in regards to yeah the labor
conversations around amazon the past few
years
what exactly is the relationship between
like a union and the direct employer
versus like a union and the government
like where does this coincide well i'm
happy to answer yeah i need
clarification so here's the thing um so
there are various uh federal rules on
the books around unions
they're not enforced very rigorously
unfortunately i wish they were enforced
more rigorously
um but you can't be
fired for trying to
start a union though i'm sure it happens
all the time like can't be retaliated
against i'm sure it happens all the time
yeah loopholes and so if you satisfy
certain standards then you can qualify
as uh a union
um and then you can negotiate um for
wages benefits or whatever you'd like
under the sun
so that the the so the legal framework
is around allowing for organization and
keeping employers from retaliating okay
uh now if you become a union um you then
can
connect with the department of labor
which is the official
government
agency that is meant to support labor
and unions and everything else
okay i just want that clarification
because it's like i understand unions
and their purpose within
the employer but i was a little bit
confused about yeah the government
relationship there in regards the
government set up rules saying hey like
you're the rules around unionizing you
should be able to do so employers
shouldn't be able to discriminate
against you and fire you or
make it more difficult though again
employers do it all the time and you
know they were it's very clear amazon
was doing it in in this instance yes uh
and then if if you uh succeed in
unionizing then there's a group of
regulators uh there's uh
like its own
kind of legal um uh tribunals uh that
they're like the national labor
relations board is meant to adjudicate
these kinds of issues so there's like a
whole legal yeah regime that comes into
effect and so
amazon spent i know in the past year was
like 4.3 million trying to block this
from happening
so what
for employers yeah what is the incentive
of course like it's just and rooted and
just not wanting to give the employees
power
oh yeah yeah that's just like what of
course it's rooted in that but it's like
is there any other things that
really push them to spend that much
money in blocking something like this
well for for amazon amazon would have
spent a lot more on that i think yeah
because you know it's like you look at
their workforce around that country it's
in the hundreds of thousands so they
weren't all to unionize um so so i i
have some sense of the backdrops of this
um so the the
union movement arose
in the mid 20th century when
manufacturing of automobiles and
everything else became like major major
employer
people were getting exploited right and
left
and then and unionizing was very very
difficult where uh like auto companies
and others would send assassins like
kill union like it was it was
essentially war
like in the in the streets like there
was a guy walter ruther who like got
shot in the face at home for being a
labor leader so this stuff was very very
hard fought very hard fought uh and then
when the unions won it was like this
massive culmination of this like
movement and they got like these laws um
uh in place labor was a massive massive
force in american life
and then uh that that time like the
things that i'm describing probably
completely alien to most people no this
is like
keep going but i have a comment then
yeah so so labor and again there was a
point when uh you know like something
like 35 to 40 of all workers were
represented by unions uh so unions were
the
force
uh they negotiated 40 hour work weeks
benefits all the stuff that a lot of
people enjoy like you know all these
things i feel like we're about to go
through this again to be honest oh i
mean
me like uh so i sincerely doubt it's
going to
um because like going from 40 to 20 of
the population over the last number of
decades uh is
really
significant um and like can that reverse
in in this way
i like i'm i'm dubious
um i'm happy again that this union has
formed and i'm happy that there are
various uh you know like environments
where these things are happening
um but there there was like this
incredible war
uh and the reason there are some reasons
i'm dubious now and that like i i think
uh maybe i'm wrong like i was i was
thinking that like the the deck has
gotten so stacked against workers that
it'd just be like i think it's going to
be i'm supportive but you know i'm not
sure this is the
is going to fix it
sorry so
uh so that that's like the great arc
it's like there's this massive conflict
uh unions became enshrined
uh then have been declining for like a
60-year period if you look at for
example the martin luther king i have a
dream speech
there were union leaders there with him
like like there were a lot of folks in
that i have a dream speech like union
leaders were hand-in-hand with the civil
rights movement the whole thing was like
you know very very uh um much like power
to the people
um and then
like the last 60 years
two generations it's gone the other
direction enormously
um now is there is there going to be a
comeback it seems like we're seeing
something of a resurgence
yeah and this is a preface for another
conversation another day because i think
it's something we can talk about for a
while but yeah we're um we talked about
last podcast me and zack about this
disconnect right now between education
and the future of work
and i'm seeing a lot of like uh yeah
younger millennials and gen z coming
into the workforce do you like what a
student of history i am jules no this is
no this is really interesting because i
just feel like that's like history
repeats itself and who knows that i know
you might not might not believe the same
but i'm just seeing this clear
uprise in how gen z is viewing work and
how even there was an article that came
out yesterday i think it might have been
the wall street journal again about how
uh young employ young employees aren't
doing cover letters for example like
just completely skipping that part and
of course we see with the great
resignation everything
there's just something cooking in
regards to this disconnect between
education and work
and also how the gig economies
gig economy passion economy which i have
my reservations about that piping up and
in regards to if people do become more
self-employed of course the health care
system in its current form does not work
for that type of system and there's
i feel like in the next yeah this decade
towards the end of it more so we're
going to see something very interesting
in regards to labor conversations
because we talked about this earlier
that seems like people are kind of
tuning out
maybe of the next election in terms of
polarization a lot of people are
depleted but this seems like a something
a lot of people are getting behind are
these labor and work conversations i'm
seeing more and more um well you would
know i mean you have your finger on the
pulse yeah i find it yeah it would be
exciting uh you know i'm all for folks
organizing
uh in in
certainly in organizations like amazon i
mean gosh like they're ideal because
uh they're made of money they're super
exploitative a lot of people work for
them like we all
use them but uh you know know that they
could be doing more so it's perfect well
you spoke about four day work weeks too
during your 2020 presidential campaign
yeah i'm all about trying to humanize
workplaces and uh and the rest of it uh
you know i i really dislike exploitation
um and there's a lot of it going on
it's going to be interesting we got i
think a good future ahead but there's
going to be a lot of
you i mean i'm so glad that you're you
know a young optimist in that way but
also see that see things very very
clearly i mean you yeah i don't know if
i'm an optimist but like
[Laughter]
uh this perspective is like we're kind
of standing amidst these uh declining
and crumbling institutions and you know
what comes next
it it'll be interesting but i'm excited
about it as long as you're excited jules
i'm excited too yes i i think that's all
we have today i think we went over
everything right yes yes we did awesome
awesome have a great week everyone have
a great week
[Music]
you